my media Hey I'm Hannibal Burres and
welcome to my new so call I'm not going
to this but you should alright let's see
you know I look at home in Chicago let's
see what's going on with Chicago what's
this
these videos are gonna be short they're
gonna be quick and to the point
I'm not going it is and see what they
suggest for me back home this weekend oh
you know what the food and drink
category I don't go to enough for the
food and drink events or food events
oh we brunch and brunch it I like that
on title oh we gotta get it we brunch
and brunch I just like it that they it
is double brunch it in there that's it
Chicago after wise old ring Korean cook
house we brunch and Brunson I'm not
going to this but we Brunson fronted I
like that
let me see what else real quick read
them in brunch bracket Road that's the
name of the place we have them in front
I like the name of it that's all it
takes with me sometimes playing ping
pong
I don't know their music at all
but I like that name pitch is playing
ping-pong
it's alliteration I don't know if
tickets are available but hey if you
don't have anything going check out the
pigeons playing ping-pong and whatever
video that's it but oh the promontory
fragments are always had some good stuff
a date Independence Day party if I was
in town I probably go to that it's Ana
Ghana Independence Day party I did I
went on African ancestry and I sent off
my site and they said I was Canadian
from the akon tribe if I was I would go
to that but I'm not going so listing web
series so lovefest security broke the
venue is 300 but the security room is
300 times two we've got 600 employees
dedicated to security making sure your
experience is one of the purest